[Música]
muy buenos días tengan todos y todos
ustedes espero que estén como dice ahí
pura vida
supondrán que tal vez le vengo a contar
la historia del cuerpo bomberos a
decirles que nos dedicamos a tres cosas
a proteger la vida la propiedad y el
medioambiente o que nuestro objetivo es
prevenir y proteger pero en realidad el
día de hoy
quiero no solamente hablarles sobre la
teoría del fuego porque es importante
conocer cómo se producen yo estoy seguro
que muchos de ustedes
se imaginarán que para producir fuego se
necesita por ejemplo oxígeno
que también vamos a necesitar
material combustible
e indudablemente para ello se requiere
también una chispa para producir fuego
y por eso este día hemos querido
indudablemente salirnos de este esquema
y pasar a otro y yo le dije a un roberto
cuando estoy interesado en venir a
ustedes
roberto yo creo que en nuestra sociedad
lo que hace falta precisamente es
en lugar de continuar en el tema de la
protección dedicarnos a analizar qué es
lo que está fallando en la prevención
y para ellos quisiera empezar
relacionando el tema con esta frase esta
es una frase muy usada en costa rica
nosotros la escuchamos constantemente
después de las emergencias siempre
después de una emergencia uno escucha a
la gente decir yo no creí que esto me
fuera a pasar a mí yo creo que esto le
pasaba a gente que digo otros lugares en
condiciones precarias gente que es muy
irresponsable pero a mí jamás me iba a
pasar en realidad esto es como una
negación a la posibilidad de que me pase
y ese es precisamente el origen para
ello
yo quería hoy contarles una historia de
algo que me ocurrió hace 19 años como
decimos nosotros hace muchos kilos atrás
cuando
una tarde
venía yo el regreso del bajo de la
altura dada con un amigo ahí caminando
poniendo el atleta y al alser como las
cinco y treinta la tarde llegamos a la
parte alta de la montaña cuando veníamos
en cargo
y el sol pues estaba brillando en el
horizonte
y de repente nos encandila mos que
invadimos el cambio el contrario
y ese día
yo solo puedo recordar dos escenas una
primera escena donde en el parabrisas se
visualizaba una sombra grande que se
acercaba
y una segunda escena cuando estaba yo
dentro de un vehículo totalmente
destrozado
un ambiente en que yo no sabía lo que
había pasado era como quieren sacaron de
este lugar y me llevaron a el otro
instantáneamente
mi amigo y yo nos preguntamos qué nos
pasó entonces
y entonces este en ese momento este
dijimos saltamos
a pesar de que tenía un carro de 15
toneladas incrustado en el de nosotros
yo todavía no relacionaba que habíamos
sufrido un grave accidente
en ese momento cuando estuvimos a punto
de salir del carro sentí un gran dolor
en la cintura
si en esa época tenía cintura y ese
dolor era muy agudo muy agudo avila
priístas y ese dolor era tan agudo que
realmente puede como si hubiera en clave
un cuchillo y yo me imagina que estaba
yo herido y no me voy y los huesos
tráquea van en ese momento yo ya empecé
a sentir de que algo grave había pasado
el tiempo realmente en esos momentos
transcurría muy extraño como por
segmentos
no era ese continuo al que uno estaba
acostumbrado
bueno
llegué al hospital y el hospital se
confirmado sin fracturas de cadera y
otras heridas más ahí múltiples heridas
yo le digo una cosa en esa época yo era
un ferviente creyente de que a mí no me
va a pasar era una persona que decía
bien jamás
y eso que en esa época yo la dejé del
departamento de prevención a los que
andan buscando riesgos y minimizando los
verdad y yo me consideraba bastante
inmune a que me ocurrieron estas cosas
bueno ocurrió que llegué al hospital y
estaba con bastantes fracturas y ahí me
pusieron una serie de prótesis en las
rodillas en la cadera me armaron algunos
médicos decían [ __ ] no volver a
caminar otros decían hay que cortar la
pierna está lista se exportaron todos
los nervios ya eso no funciona
muchas preguntas me decían en el
hospital sólo una tenía completa certeza
y era cuando me preguntaban y llevaba el
cinturón puesto
negativo lo demás pues será realmente
muchas cosas que en la cabeza me daban
vueltas
en esa época yo era muy aficionado a
todo lo que se llama la aventura que
vamos al cuadra que el kayak el
paracaidismo a la montaña cualquier cosa
que se ponía por delante que fuera
aventura yo me mandaba inclusive hasta
manejar en una ruta 32 imagínense que
jugaba
bueno realmente esa frase a mí no me va
a pasar este estaba muy arraigada en mí
era un fiel devoto de que a mí no me va
a pasar pero me pasó verdad me pasó y
estuve varios meses en el hospital de
links viendo todos los días eso yo sabía
cuántos huecos tenía cada difusor
tenía un cronometrado de la hora del
desayuno el almuerzo y la cena era mi
vida era comer aquí de guerra y estar
viendo y si el brazo era una época de
mucha frustración yo tiene mucha rabia o
sea todo el día pasada porque a mí
porque a mí porque a mí
era un tema recurrente entender que era
lo que me había pasado y éste no era lo
que yo estaba yo estaba en la negación
en indicación
bueno un día un super notición me dice
héctor y yo para mí fue una cosa
maravillosa cuando dijeron que iba para
el cierre entonces el alemán en la silla
ahí y rapidito me monté en la silla y me
dijeron que ese crédito
ahorita años usted vamos a sacar
aquellos primeros y yo no ahora
halle rapidísimos desesperado buscando
el sol del viento el calor se verá
árboles cosas que uno realmente sabe
todos los días pero cuando lo privan de
eso es otra cosa
en mi desesperación de llegar al patio
me equivoqué personados y cuando llegué
a un salón y me perdí me encontré una
serie de personas todos muchachos de 23
13 años
acostados
y yo me animé a ingresar un poco para
ver qué era lo que estaba pasando
y vi que bailaban que pasaban y eran
todos los padres ricos
carrillo de 23 3 años le vamos a
preguntar le habían pasado accidentes
muy parecidos al que me pasaron a mí
y yo dije
inclusive accidentes menores al que me
pasó a mí y estaban cuadripléjicos
entonces yo dije aquí hay algo raro está
llevando y quejándome por el dolor y por
la tristeza que voy a hacer esto lo pasó
me sirve una pierna me sirve
el cerebro más o menos me sirve entonces
yo digo qué pasa aquí hay algo que no
está en ese momento yo creo que empecé a
entender una de las lecciones más
importantes y que es el factor común de
muchas emergencias y es el aceptar y
aceptar que me puede pasar no es una
cosa fácil porque les digo que lo
vivimos todos los días
aceptar que uno le puede pasar no es
algo fácil de decirlo tal vez fácil
decirlo pero no fácil de interiorizarlo
y yo decía estos muchachos
cuadripléjicos no se dan por vencidos
siguen adelante la sigue impulsando
y ahí están y yo ahí llorando porque me
quebró la cadera
bueno vale para el patio finalmente y
ahí para que no quiere caldo dos tazas
tomé me encuentro en señora y negro
grandote de limón y de consolarla
y me pidió que el marcar el teléfono y
ahí entramos en conversación y le digo y
qué le pasó cuánto tiene estar en la
silla mis 65 años
me dice que a los 17 el tuvo accidente
allá no sólo carriles lleva 65 años
transfieras ya tenía llagas en algas por
eso es que estaba ahí para circular
entonces yo en ese momento dije si
definitivamente
hay que aceptar y me ocurrió algo raro
ese día la frustración la cual era el
enojo todo todo para abajo ya en la
tarde yo era otro ya había aceptado
lo que me había pasado de una forma pues
impactante para mí porque contrarrestar
el caso de uno como el de otro tal vez
no ayudó nio pero a veces son las cosas
que nos llevan a la realidad
bien un proceso de recuperación de la
cámara silla rueda de la silla de ruedas
andadera delantera las muletas de la
muleta el bastón y fue un proceso donde
mucha gente me ayudó por ahí está mamá
en algún lado y tuvo que repetir la
elección de chávez volverme a enseñar a
caminar para atrás y entonces en ese
proceso yo conocí gente que realmente
tiene mucha voluntad y tiene mucho
carisma gente que
pregunto yo quien estaría dispuesto a
limpiar el trasero a un desconocido
a los que están al lado soy yo de
izquierda le limpian el trasero sí y
además no motivarían a seguir adelante
más me ponga le diga siga adelante no se
brinda realmente hay gente con una
vocación increíble que lo motiva a uno a
seguir adelante y tienen eso ahí aprendí
indudablemente una lección muy
importante la unidad porque porque nos
queremos autosuficientes
doña todas pero cuando usted tiene que
esperar a que alguien le traiga el cacho
para que orine ustedes dice toda vez que
aquí no hay gente tan autosuficiente
como no querer ya estamos dependemos de
los demás nadie es autosuficiente y es
que se lo cree yo creo que están graves
problemas y probablemente en nuestras
vidas nos toca ser creernos
autosuficientes pero la realidad es que
eso no existe bueno
pasó el tiempo porque en la oficina y en
la oficina
yo era todo pasa por mí
el madrid es pensable ahí el que todo lo
tiene que ver y qué sorpresa para mí
todo continuo normal el trabajo se hizo
día a día nada se atrasó con suerte se
decía lo mejor verdad y entonces yo dije
yo era y no
nadie es indispensable nadie
indispensable y eso fue una lección que
yo la aprendí ahí viéndolo y yo pienso
está bien la indispensable y es lo
correcto por supuesto por supuesto que
lo correcto el mundo no puede depender
de personas no puede depender de que si
alguien se muere todo se acabó eso lo
correcto que las cosas continúen y
cuando uno no acepta eso vive una
contradicción con el mundo porque eso no
lo correcto y eso no es lo que era la
felicidad
bueno
de todo esto el proceso de
de recuperación o un día que ocurrió
algo especial ese día
el pie no se movía y me dijeron si usted
no mueve el pie
el sistema ya estaba todo preparado del
sistema eléctrico no servía entonces me
dijeron si no mueve el pie no va a
funcionar entonces
me puse yo a tratar de mandar las
señales para que el dedito se moviera y
el dedito corto no se movía
un amigo me dijo por ahí que pasó de los
compas que nos hacen hospitales le dice
el cerebro muy carga usted tiene que
seguir mandando la señal mandando la
señal esto es como lo que hacemos ahora
con la expresa verdad hay rutas alternas
que todos ya no sabíamos que existían
pero ya sabemos que existen y esas rutas
alternas nos llevan al destino después
de un tiempo hasta el más rápido por ahí
y manda la señal y manda la señal y
mantén la señal y finalmente un día el
dedo se movió para que alegría no de
viento pero ese día yo lloré además tomé
esta foto que está por ahí
si hubiera habido whatsapp así 19 años
sigo la pongo el perfil clamando a todo
mundo hasta me invento un vídeo viral y
esas cosas
también aprendí ese día con el dedito
que nunca nunca es una lección tarde ya
muchas las conocen pero muy cierta nunca
apreciamos lo que tenemos hasta que lo
perdemos por eso yo los invito en este
momento ahí cada uno en su lugar a que
mande una señal y muevan el dedito corto
eso es algo maravilloso para hacer es un
maravilloso
y ese día pues también aprendí que a mí
sí me puede pasar diez años después ya
no hay enojo o resentimiento siento que
tuve una segunda oportunidad y aprendí
que a mí sí me puede pasar eso que a
todos nos puede pasar
escuché una pequeña explosión en la
cocina me levanté abrir la puerta de mi
cuarto para ir a ver qué sucedía cuando
abrí la puerta de mi cuarto ya no pude
pasar hacia la sala estaba completamente
la mitad de la casa en llamas dos amigos
míos una de mis amigas y yo decidimos de
meternos al mar la playa estaba rotulada
con mensajes de precaución estamos los
cuatro ahí ningún momento sentimos como
que el malo jalón ya yo vi el mar como
bien en calma más o menos se halla yo no
veía olas entonces es donde más usted y
yo me di cuenta que yo estaba bastante
adentro y yo lo que hago es empezar a
tratar de nadar con más fuerza los hay o
digo diosito ya no puedo más y
simplemente mojar ir si yo quería
conocer a los ojos y dejarme ir y veamos
si quieta para mi trabajo yo salí de mi
casa
nos veríamos de mi lado iba solo yo para
que venían dos carros y el señor giró a
su izquierda invadiendo bibi carril
estoy sobreviviente a un accidente de
descarga eléctrica mientras instalado en
antena yo estaba arriba del palo
y sosteniendo la antena para que no se
vuelvan a cable porque estaba muy cerca
de los cables si acaso un metro de
distancia
la antena giro y ahí recibí la descarga
y yo escuchaba a mi papá
que desesperado que decía se madre me
dijo dios que hago que hago yo siempre
pensé a mí no me va a pasar
le pasará a otros pero a mí no vemos las
noticias de que pasó eso pasó lo otro y
hay verdad pobrecitos o qué pecado y
ojalá que y que puede estar bien pero
nunca nos preguntamos por qué se me
puede pasar a mí y bueno y no va a hacer
levanta con todas las ganas de ir a
trabajar y todo y como jamás pide que
esto le puede pasar sólo porque uno dice
que a qué le pasó a mí no cualquier
momento le puede pasar o no
en mi trabajo yo normalmente veo cómo
las personas descubren en las gracias
que no son infalibles el año pasado
murieron 30 personas en su casa durante
un incendio 62 electrocutados 149
murieron en accidentes acuáticos 454 en
accidentes de tránsito más muchos más
que quedaron lesionados realmente creer
que esto no nos puede pasar es algo
incorrecto
los mitos cosas para terminar primero
que admitamos que nos puede pasar les
digo que es fácil decirlo pero es fácil
es difícil interiorizar lo que
consideramos que podemos morir ahogados
que podemos abrir un accidente que
nosotras te puede quemar eso hay que
aceptarlo y segundo que no nos
preocupemos que no nos preocupemos que
nos ocupemos porque ocuparse es lo que
sí debemos de hacer no debemos vivir en
una preocupación ayer me decía mi hija
valentina que le vas a ir a decir que se
van a morir luego no porque la gente que
ve te está muy viva enfermo y pinillos
no no van a morir ya ellos saben que se
van a morir lo que les voy a decir
es que no deben anticipar su salida de
este mundo y segundo que no deben ser
una carga para alguien más esas cosas
son las que yo creo que vale la pena
saber y entonces tomemos acción pongamos
un detector de humo identificamos las
salidas ponemos un extintor enseñamos le
a alguien a marcar y dar la dirección de
la casa tomemos acciones que realmente
nos lleven indudablemente a minimizar
y el cuarto bombero de costa rica
amamos lo que hacemos para cuidar lo que
ustedes aman
[Aplausos]
[Música]